so just trying to I'm trying to warm
your brain back up okay because you
notice like why am i what am I saying
dead because this is our signal okay
you're in the complex meaning the
complex set here okay
now how does this work if you want to
show that something as a fact of being
active living quarters in a possible
right you are going to take advantage of
that factor dear what is the factor
theorem
how do you stay under snot with you okay
rather than X I could use X I suppose
but I'm really tend to use I reserved X
and Z for my variables so I want a
constant of some term tapis I'm gonna
corner that's the way I stated it if F
of a is what your equals zero and then
now we stated it this way
Thank You pollinators because we are
other than dealing with ones that were
in the realities of course here all I
need to really slightly adjust is if I
for this them and them right so this is
simply so I would say I would say if of
I right because that's my that's my
constant here that I'm being shifted by
right and I'm just going to evaluate it
and it's important that I evaluate it
like properly you step by step i cubed 2
I square and in here of course well you
can take out two of the eyes to be
negative one so this is maybe hi this is
this is 3 this is 0 right at this point
what I would say is okay I have a result
yeah and is resting on this kind of
factor theorem
ok so I think it is best to say I mean
you can probably get away honestly with
just concluding there but I'm gonna say
bye
Zen - I is a factor
all of that so you can see okay this is
not I was gonna say there's no contact
with these companies it's not
complicated
it's it's using these simple ideas we
had before but just real recalibrating
again to have the complex arithmetic
right remember scientific rules I help
you this time
right what way being else again is a
simple question okay but we want to do
this over a different number sets so you
might have to remember okay the Q the Q
actually stands for something what is Q
stand for it's there's a question
so if questions are what give you
fractions so this this means the
rational owners okay maybe other two
we're more familiar with the reals and
the complex so the way you will
encounter a question like this will say
factorize such-and-such polynomial over
the field rational numbers or the field
of rhythms or occasionally the set of
rational real okay so what that means is
okay if all you've got is these guys how
can you how can you factorize this and
what that signals to me is okay if
rational numbers are okay the only thing
I'd be outlawed from really is
certicates are not rational okay so how
far can I factorize that guy without
appealing to any square roots metal
cubes or anything like that okay so I
look at this right and if you fact I
know the fours of the truce freaked you
out a little bit but if you do just do a
brief substitution in your mind for Z
squared as you said squared as you so
what is this this is a reducible to a
quadratic it's not a quadratic but I can
reduce it to a quadratic you swear it
must be minus 6 as a simple factor one
of the two numbers
yeah plus 3 negative 2 so for Part A I'm
going to say
that is equal to now just recalibrating
for the fact that I substituted for this
with right so I'm gonna go to Z squared
plus 3 and then squared minus 2 okay do
you have a look right now we'll look at
the numbers for all of my coefficients
today all rational no I said mark my
words I said the coefficients
coefficients I'm not solving anything
it's not equal to anything we can't
solve this right you can find its roots
but that and I said nothing else I said
fact all right this is maximized all of
the numbers I've used to factorize this
other or rational and the answers they
are I've got a 1 3 a 1 and a negative
I'm both happy
now the reason I had to stop me is
because there is a factorization that
would come pretty second nature to you
which I've been do out of that second
binomial but I'm not allowed to do it
under the simple rational numbers what's
the factorization I could do yeah good I
could do difference of squares here
right like 2 is not a proper swindle but
that doesn't mean a concrete difference
of squares I just can't do it for a
while I'm still in the rational numbers
that makes its up still limited here so
if a part baby I'm just going to record
go from there and I'm gonna say okay
I've got this is square plus 3 at the
front but I can do difference of squares
is this now that I'm allowed to use any
real number on line which includes
irrational numbers so I'm going to write
this I said minus 2 and plus
there's my differences with okay sit
down at this point I just have to choose
again all the coefficients real it's up
yes right can I go any further answer no
nobody they are going into a
so by the way you can know also you can
stop once you hit the linear factors do
you remember this right the mini fact is
is [ __ ] you can possibly do it down
in some way linear factors are kind of
the corresponding things you prime
numbers for composites right
do you remember I can take another
lifetime for think back to you selling
like this is what I'm teaching you seven
at the moment right see you can break
this down into a series of prime numbers
right now you can do this in a variety
of ways cuz 24th I'm going to go to six
and four that brings me down to the two
three two and two
right so once you get down to here
though these prime numbers your you
can't go any further
rather than you can introduce ones but
this is a primary reason why the ones
are the prime numbers so that you can't
just go on endlessly of your tree never
ends okay so 2 3 2 or 2 2 cubed times 3
that's your prime factorization what do
you need Lydia ones it's just like an
appliance you can't get any of you fool
thanks babe ok until you get 2 for this
so what am I going to do with this
quadratic determine through the hair
- it's okay so I have a choice I could
be a directly but I think it is helpful
to form this as difference of squares to
write as density so this is really said
square by this okay because I'm going to
buy this here
I need another - to counteract them but
- I'll introduce is a square number
right is that make sense so that is that
I'm buddy's old term that's free to a
square number as well it's it's root
three swim through that is that okay so
now you can see the difference of
squares super obviously in fact I really
could have written I three spread
because they both being spread you happy
with that doesn't sneaky and what you
see where I was getting then I've got
like to review which I already had and
now I'm gonna actually venture